there's tons of stuff that I do and some
of it takes off some of it doesn't but
what is really amazing about 2017 flip
challenges Crowley in the shop get him
out of here no no no I mean keep it
rolling but like you can fit I mean just
go focus on me because I don't want to
get any more face time what's really
amazing is when
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah I said I was raised in the
days of my faith the screen name back
then when I was only worried about my
pop friends now my circle again is
smaller all these people like to fake
man and to be honest I don't hear today
there Chuck and it's a 251 of the
askgaryvee show
pretty excited about this because I'm a
huge NBA fan and we have a real-life NBA
player here with us Mason Plumlee is
here what part of your game was toughest
for you if you said at a macro the thing
that was hardest for you to develop in
your game yeah that you can rewind to
now like we're going very macro
basketball right now what would that be
like is it like Celeste last summer I
wanted to change the way in which I shot
the ball my long period theory not only
it's a little crazy yeah and I was crazy
boy we have something ours felt like
this
Tiger Woods broke down a swing that is
one master I had every worship but I
wasn't breaking down I was bringing up I
love it I wanted to change so and you
know it was very there's a lot of times
I didn't see progress I didn't you know
I got with the coach and we're in the
gym everyday and it was frustrating
stuff they'll operate it didn't you have
to have muscle memory and habits that
are hard to break if you can tune them
wrong for so long so that was something
that that I you know I just fully
committed to last summer in and they're
like you'd like the question said there
are a lot of times we read but where are
we right now and not so I feel very gone
still finished so in it I'm still on
that journey I'm very happy
where my form is you know I hit more
jump shots this year than I have any
year in the league and that's not I feel
like I have a base in a form that I can
build a comment you need to improve its
make so glad you stopped by man by
Shravan from stick with everywhere and
if I'm real you ain't gotta play this
first I teleport of the most audited to
live the don't run like a post office
today we're 30 put them on the front of
hat or something that keep it authentic
when think long-term you want better
businesses you're a better human being
and in this clip you'll see me talking
passionately about yeah one more time
there's a little rant you can show all
that stuff type maybe you can speed it
up and then maybe show little parts what
you just witness was how I create when
you feel it do it came up a little idea
never thought about before excited about
what's going on with my podcast let me
game afire crazy that little piece of
content in this little one-minute
Facebook or Instagram or whatever video
if it goes that long is about this which
is you need to act on when you feel it
so if you feel something you act on it
this is just meta on top of meta on top
of meta right like I just felt it I did
it and now I'm making another piece of
content about what I just did because I
feel it always react and do the amount
of people that just had an idea to do a
contest on their podcast to grow
awareness on their podcast but then
we'll have six meetings ponderous and
never get around to doing it is very
high the difference for meals and
operators when I feel it I just go into
do mode I felt it right now and I get it
for the podcast I felt that there was a
learn lesson in it and I'm making an
original video piece of content do do do
you really understand what has happened
with this video clip you've got a shot
cool yeah make a list of the laying the
people and [ __ ] we're gonna win man
like you got it's actually such a basic
system really and it really is I just
it's hard to wrangle the tiger you know
but make the [ __ ] list and just
[ __ ] and you're in charge of me like
15 minutes if does they might get me so
I was a DNF student and and was an
immigrant that came to America with
nothing so it makes sense for me to hear
you say that because that's what
happened to me right in my early 20s I
didn't have anything you know I didn't
have any success that I could hang my
hat on or relationships or even I didn't
even know like what Ivy League school
kids look like when I'm telling you like
real extreme so when I started getting
my 20s and building my wine business I I
you know I had it in me but I was like
wait a minute
it's even happening to me now by the way
this will continue to happen to you if
you're if you're actually an intuitive
base winner even now like listen when I
hang out with antiques man see people
like I'm smart these people like in the
game that's being played now right like
well honestly that's honestly the
reverse Mike that's what caught my
attention to me it's art its DNA like
you'll get some in young brown eyes it's
like either you have it binary it's just
right now
we are because they're all being changed
by the same thing yeah multifaceted
correct
it's like unemotional truth to the
reality of the situation
[ __ ] that's how I am like keeping up I
would turn this into a pumpkin patch
selling company tomorrow if I thought it
was the right thing I mean it when you
are in a place where you become
completely unemotional and all you're
doing is reacting to culture like I
don't need to like I don't care if the
me goes this [ __ ] or bad or good or if
at Lana if Danny Glover of Childish
Gambino's good bad or indifferent I just
care that people care I don't get to
decide the market does so I think the
brands that are able to capture a moment
are the ones that intrigued me the ones
that actually capture my attention are
the ones who can show me that it's their
absolute thesis not the one time that
got them to make the money of course
brother
that's the game that's not a this is my
title like it's just a conversion the
tsingy being an arts back in the day
when your whatever however right when
I'm an art director will be different
subject right yeah and guess what even
when you get to the end the only
difference is I don't have a boss
everybody because your boss it like all
the way up and then you think no no it
goes the other way and the whole thing
flips on you and everybody's above you
like think about that right but I get
right right
and what people don't get is when you
get to the top so everyone's like oh I'm
down here and one day I'm going to be up
here and I'm going to be a boss and it's
getting better and then like we just
said it's not and then we think the one
day like I run my own design shop one
day but you don't understand is when you
actually make it to the top the whole
thing flips on you and then everybody's
above you the junior designer in this
talking company I report to more people
than that personís got it [ __ ] gnarly
but it's dope like like if you've got
the chops
it's more back with that like like it's
um it's just it's a never-ending game of
the box people's opinions form over time
so but I break people I get it right
more because so because you act yeah
acting is the only way to do it I bring
people to after the data correct yeah
not like put up a front or your your
authentically your awesome self you're
not this not your stick
yeah that's your truth and that was
better real a long time ago otherwise me
too which is why everybody pisses me off
so much
[Music]
[Applause]
hello been here since mid-november
right after somebody Atticus projects
welcome to here yeah like I'm building
this for the rest of my life yeah what
do I want to make yeah I want to make
the [ __ ] motion picture of my life
right first it's like I want to make I
want to make content that sells eight
million raid glasses I want to make a
animated 17-minute film that wins an
Academy Award I want to make a VR 360
experience and nobody's ever made before
and it's critically acclaimed but sold
bagels for a [ __ ] store in st. Louis
I want to make a video that's seven
hundred dollars and changes Schenectady
New York entire POV to the world because
it went viral like I won't do everything
I'm a great weekend man I think anything
I can ever help reach out okay yeah I
really appreciate it thanks Kerry my
pleasure man I'm glad you came over
yeah as you soon
yeah I mean that's the game right
looking what do you need for me great
understood I know that it's in my inbox
reset Semak I'll resend that I will give
you a firm financial number on Tuesday
right right like like right yeah the
views are just so sick I honestly think
this is the best spot nothing I don't
know I'm like there's Madison Square
Garden that's like where my knowledge of
this city ends and it's literally
changing our company we will never lose
if I meet with every single person
[Music]
dude that tweet you put out last night
or this morning have me so fired up work
work for it so what we basically believe
in the same share yeah I love it
same exact [ __ ] where I hear you say my
work damn that's a different way to say
something yeah you're saying the same
thing and you know so it's bad you know
I'm doing what I'm doing and um yeah
thank you now I will rewind book just
which one of this book on got my second
his book did you get out of work did
this you know it's so crazy you are the
best because this is literally what I've
been talking with them about I'm coming
up with a kid's cartoon beautiful I
believe in this [ __ ]
so may 2nd so here's their this oh [ __ ]
Tuesday link it up my man jack goes got
a book go get it for all your kids check
I wish you well man driver
thanks for stopping by well I let me go
see choose that yeah Tyler O'Connor Syd
nothing that's of your thought okay
Bob said you got lucky existed it was a
photo because photo down that's right
he's got it haha all right I got a spell
Tyler will see Jacko Tuesday let's go
CJ
yeah probably so I don't need too much
you know yeah but I want to do some hey
guys oh yeah we're husband boxes this
really makes me happy to be very fred
feels very much like the kind of company
I wanted to build yeah thank you not
poor mock me Oh Luke you don't scare me
I don't think you be mean anything in
life it's just so he understands that
synthesizes everything which is I don't
know how to answer your question because
I don't know if they just have a moment
or they've proven to me Bezos has proven
to me he's unemotional you know he will
innovate to the death and he believes in
his thesis staying with me I will the
original building this company is to
build the scalable version of my
behavior which is Mars let's go let's go
buy up all the outdoor media because at
first I will be valuable so a trade
attention hacking culture like knowing
what the [ __ ] is actually happening
either I know what's happening in
Silicon Valley for real or I don't
either you get tricked and stay you know
you have to have an opinion on glass
here you have to have an opinion on
Conde Nast yet there's a pane on
snapchat and and Nike a depth of an
opinion and either you're right or
you're wrong and what I try to spend
almost all my time on is being right
it's all about that you can never waver
from your opinion because first of all
either you're good enough you're not and
it actually doesn't matter
right now I think so yeah it's really
fascinating I basically play an entire
life that doesn't value the current and
so you know what that means means you
get to be religious about it and you
never waver I really Joe Klecko here
comes the pick
[Music]
you
[Music]
you